tomorrow is the 75th anniversary of the
use of the most powerful weapon
ever employed in human history in 1945
the united states dropped the second of
two atomic bombs on japan
in an effort to hasten the end of world
war ii the target was the port city of
nagasaki
the first bomb was dropped on hiroshima
on august 6th
the two bombings killed more than 200
000 people most of them civilians
on thursday in hiroshima a scaled back
memorial ceremony was held for survivors
and their families
remy innocencia spoke with one survivor
whose goal is to rid the world
of nuclear weapons the mushroom cloud
rose
menacingly over hiroshima 75 years ago
an event seared into world history and
more so in the mind of toshiko tanaka
she was right under that cloud just six
years old
and miraculously survived i remember the
horror of that day
blinding light like thousands of strobe
lights my body thrown to the ground
at 81 she says she's been blessed to
live
her mission now banning all nuclear
weapons
75 years after surviving the bombing i'm
all the more determined to help rid the
world of nuclear arms
what became hiroshima's ground zero was
once its humming commercial district of
nakajima
with city hall restaurants and cafes
tanaka pictured here with her father
lived close by
but on august 6 1945 the enola gay
super fortress bomber dropped its
payload on the city
a five ton nuclear bomb nicknamed little
boy
the atom bomb exploded just a third of a
mile over this river
killing an estimated 80 thousand people
instantly and leveling about 90 percent
of the city
but that building now known as the
atomic bomb dome
was one of the few things left standing
a testament to the tragedy of war it now
stands aligned with tributes to peace
the peace flame and peace memorial
museum newly renovated in time for the
75th anniversary
dimmed rooms spotlight the day of the
bombing irradiated artifacts tell the
stories of those who died in an
instant torn clothes a tricycle a lunch
never eaten photographs of burn victims
hang on the walls
next to artwork by survivors of hot
melting skin
and black radioactive rain through her
own artwork tonica still
processes that fateful day 75 years ago
the united states bombed your city do
you have any
criticism for america we were full of
rage
at first but once we saw the americans
it was clear they were just like
us years later she even met clifton
truman
daniel grandson of president harry
truman who ordered the bombing
there will be a time in the future when
there are
no more surviving hiroshima victims what
do you want the world to remember
eliminating nuclear weapons is the path
to peace
ensuring this tragedy is never repeated
and tonica manages
one last line in english please make
many friends from
other countries when you do so you are
moving the world towards peace
a remarkable woman who survived a
nuclear bombing
yet still has peace in her heart for cbs
this morning saturday
raymie innocencio hiroshima japan
sounds pretty good trying to meet many
different people from many different
countries
yeah and there was a long period of time
she didn't want to talk about it she
said because it was so painful but
realize how important it was
to speak out and important to remember
as raymie points out there will be a
time not too far away when no survivors
are left so
exactly really interesting to hear from
her